why did the prime minister's press
secretary allegra stratton have to
resign from her job
minister
that's right i i bitterly regret
allegra's resignation i think it was
very sad and i think she did an
outstanding job uh but
i i i do i i do particularly
particularly uh since she was the the
one who coined the uh expression coal
cars cash and trees uh which enabled the
uk uh to deliver a fantastic cop 26
summit last year
[Music]
allegra strucken
laughed at breaking the rules
she resigned
the prime minister then claimed he was
furious at her behavior and accepted her
resignation
professor neil ferguson broke the rules
he also resigned
the prime minister said that was the
right thing to do
the former health secretary broke the
rules he too resigned
the prime minister tried to claim he
sacked him
why does the prime minister think
everybody else's actions have
consequences
except his own
i i thank the right honourable gentleman
i see i feel he's in some kind of doctor
who time warp but we had this uh we had
this conversation yesterday uh mr
speaker and i
uh why i bitterly regret uh receiving an
fpn i i apologize uh to the house uh but
he asks about the actions for which i
take responsibility now i'll tell him
we're gonna get on with delivering for
the british people
making sure and making sure that we
power out of the the problems that kovid
has left us and more people in work than
there were before the pandemic mr
speaker fixing our energy problems and
leading the world in standing up to the
aggression of vladimir putin those are
all subjects about which i think he
could reasonably ask questions now
[Applause]
these are strange answers from a man who
yesterday claimed to be making a humble
apology
[Music]
does the prime minister actually accept
that he broke the law
speaker i've been absolutely clear that
i i humbly accept what the uh what the
police have uh have said i've paid the
fixed penalty notice and mr speaker what
i think the country and what i think the
whole house i would really rather do is
get on with the things for which we were
elected
deliver on our promises to the british
people
you could not have clearer evidence of
the intellectual bankruptcy
they have no plans they have no plans
for energy
and they have no they have no plans
to fix the economy
sit down i won't tell you what you've
got to say but i can't hear when you're
talking that way i'm here in the church
please if you can help me no i think
we'll live out of it
the state of it the party of peel and
churchill reduced to shouting and
screaming
in defense of this lawbreaker